[MUSIC PLAYING]
What are we going
to do today, Barret?
We are going to get all
up in the closure business.
(SINGING) Closures.
Closures, and we're
going to embrace them.
And it's going to be great.
All right, well, let's do it.
So what are we
trying to accomplish?
So you have, I
guess, four contacts.
You sent me some code ahead
of time, and were like,
here's where we're going today.
And I was like, cool.
And then I ate lunch.
[LAUGHS]
So let's take a look
at the server function,
just so we can see this.
And then we're going to
kind of double what's here.
So we're going to have two
buttons for rolling the dice.
And we're going to try to
hide a lot of this logic,
so that we can kind
of say, from 23 to 38,
that's like, roll the dice.
And that's it, we can
just listen to things.
And we can try to
hide this away.
And I think it's really
useful when you're
trying to make your server
function not over 1,000
lines of code, and
it can actually
be maintainable and
reusable, but still
use expressions that Shiny
is wanting you to use.
And I think we'll
kind of see it happen
and how it's kind of not
easy to do unless we use
some closures with [INAUDIBLE].
So--
[SIGHS]
--let's try to see on how--
what would we need
to do if we were
going to have two dice
buttons, roll the dice buttons,
and two button outputs?
Let's kind of change
the code from there.
Right, so you're
saying we want roll dice,
roll another dice.
Yes.
And then you want
output for dice
one and then an
output for dice two.
Sounds great.
OK.
So I would go to the UI.
That's usually my-- so
I would do something
like Action button,
and then typing out
all my variable names,
make them consistent.
I hope that all of the comments
are about how semantically--
the grammar of die versus dice.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
Truly what I hope for.
OK, so we did this thing here.
Why did I name
that codelike_text?
That Is not a good name.
All right, so we're going
to do this, dice_02.
Actually, let's do
output_dice_02, placeholder =
TRUE.
And then, I'm actually going
to make this the change,
so that it's consistent.
But before we do anything else,
let's get in here and change--
do I need to-- is there
anything else that-- no,
because I think we did
everything with reactive.
So I think we're OK.
I don't think we're--
Just 51, yeah, codelike_text.
Yeah
No.
Yeah.
All right, so we've added in
the UI elements, which we have.
So we got that.
We can't really tell
which one is which.
That's OK.
And so, now we need
to hook them up.
Because if I rule
the second dice.
Nothing.
But the first one
should still work.
[INAUDIBLE], yeah, we're good.
Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So if we were
to do this again,
I think ONE of
the easiest ways--
let's just walk through
the 30 seconds of pain
that this will be.
So let's copy 33 to
48, because that's
all the logic that we need.
If you want, we can put
it-- yeah, right after 48,
that works.
Right.
So let's add some
labels here, just
so I remember what we're doing.
So this is original
code one dice.
And then, that's definitely
not right, but that's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
All right.
And we would also need,
let's duplicate 70 to 73
and have that print
output_dice_02.
OK.
All right, I broke everything.
Yes.
Just kidding.
Well, I guess we did,
with that code, right?
So if we run this, nothing--
Yeah, that won't--
[LAUGHS] So we
just duplicate it.
Which we expect,
because we haven't
changed any of our inputs.
We just duplicated our code.
The only thing
we've really changed
is this, although we
haven't hooked that up.
Yes, that's still hooked up,
but it's hooked up to this.
And so, we would
also need to, then, 52,
54, all of those variables
need to be renamed,
like last roll
two, dice bow two.
Are we doing this?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're going
to go through it,
just to experience
how not fun this is.
So you're saying that my
first approach to all of this
is actually wrong.
Because this is 100%
what I would do,
is come in and just be frank,
let me duplicate the code.
It is not wrong.
It is just not efficient.
Hmm.
So, it will work,
and that's great.
That's what we want.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
And then, last_roll_02.
Nope, wait, mm, No, yeah.
Yep, yep.
Last_roll_02 bindEvent(dice)--
is it dice_val?
Oof, I'm already lost.
Dice_val_02.
And that dice_val_02,
and then we'll
just change 76 to dice_val_02,
and keep the other variables
as they were.
All right, this should actually
work with both buttons.
Yeah.
OK.
Because we don't have to change
the values inside the function,
because it's really
the label of this.
It's the label of the
reactive that we're accessing.
So we could have every
variable inside our reactive
the same name.
But what's going to affect
it is this guy right here.
Now we could, if we wanted
to change the max number,
we could change that
here, but we want to.
Yes.
If we had a different
number selector, then maybe
we do select max number 2.
But we're both reading
from the same max number.
Yeah, and as you said,
with the reactive,
the variable, like new roll, is
scoped to the expression of 54.
So it will not leak out, and
so we don't need to rename it.
Yep.
So this works.
This is awesome.
Done.
Yeah, all right,
recording done.
Good.
Now what if I
said, let's do it
for 10 buttons and 10 outputs.
Now this just gets icky.
And it might work.
We could get clever in
doing some square brackets
with a four loop and
a couple other things.
But let's instead make
a helper function.
And I think that'll just
kind of resolve everything.
OK.
This'll be a little
bit of a journey.
But in the end, we'll come out
on the other end of the tunnel
here.
Because it's kind of like
you can't do it halfway.
It's all in.
I feel like a hobbit.
Yeah, this is definitely a
journey outside of the shire.
Going on an adventure.
Yeah.
So, like how we were doing
other things with functions,
like, oh, we see duplicated
code, let's make a function.
Let's just go ahead and
do that, and then just
kind of roll with this.
All right.
Yep, I'll let you drive.
OK.
Let's make a function.
Well, what are we functionizing?
Are we going to
take everything--
are we going to take 36 through
81 and functionize all of that?
For this purpose,
let's not do the output.
OK.
Let's only do 36 to 52.
So we're kind of
doing 36 through 50.
So we are going to functionize--
[COUGHS]
--one dice roll.
(WHISPERING) [INAUDIBLE],,
we can just ignore that.
All right.
That's not right.
Yeah, and we wouldn't
need the return--
yeah, yeah, perfect.
And then, I, personally, just
go ahead and copy 40 to 56
and put it in, and then
we adjust it from there.
OK.
So, one way that we
could get around this
without doing closures and
things, because we know exactly
what we're doing, just
as an example, is we
could pass in a key.
a button key.
And a max number key
would be a nice one.
So, just for fun, let's go
ahead and go down that route
and say, yeah, button_key
and max_number_key.
and We'll default
max_number_key to equal quote
select_max_number,
like the name there.
Yeah.
OK.
Awesome.
And then, let's go ahead
and use these key values.
So, 99% of the
time we do things,
we are accessing input
values via the dollar.
But you can also access them via
bracket bracket, square bracket
square bracket.
So let's update 40
and 42 to listen
to the max_number_key variable.
So it'll be like, input
bracket bracket max_number_key.
OK.
Great.
And we can do this
again down there.
Oops, no, autocomplete
got me, got me good.
And the reason we're
doing double brackets
is because single brackets,
these return to single item.
Whereas if there's
more than one item,
the single brackets will
return all of those items.
Yes.
Yes, single brackets
returns a subset list,
and double brackets returns
the value for the key value
of the list, yep.
I feel like this is our power,
is that I use vague, amorphous,
handwavey terms.
And then you're, like, yes,
the technical vocabulary
that you're trying to use is.
[LAUGHS]
Yes.
But it's good, right?
If you want multiple,
you do single.
If you only want single
item, you do multiple.
So we're selecting a single
value, which we've already set
here to our select_max_number.
So our select_max_number
is this guy right here.
And so, that's like saying
13 equals max_number_key.
Yeah, we're good.
This looks great.
I'm following
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's do the same treatment
to 46 with button one.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
So that'll be
input of button_key.
And do we need to
change button_key to--
no, because if we
want to generalize it,
and we've got two buttons--
Yeah.
So we'll go ahead and leave it
empty, meaning that's required.
If you wanted, you could
give it a default value,
like for yourself Just, that
way, you can run things faster.
But I think it's good as is.
Leave it.
All right.
[SIGHS] So let's go
ahead and use our function.
So let's just look at
the functions right now.
Last_roll is scoped, great.
We then do a reactive, where
we listen to some max number.
And we make sure that
it's a new number compared
to last_roll, 141.
And then we returned
that new number.
But that reactivity
won't run until we
have a button press, which,
so we found that event, great.
And then, we update
the last role
given the dice value, whenever
the dice value changes.
OK.
Cool.
Because [INAUDIBLE].
Like we could just--
Yeah, yeah, that works.
But it does need to
be the last thing
in the function, at least.
So, OK, cool, this is good.
And we can actually
have multiple calls
to one dice roll.
And we don't need to rename
the variables internally.
They'll all just be
constant, just awesome.
So let's actually see if we
can change the code below
to use this method.
Ah, OK.
So, we theoretically shouldn't
need another last roll.
Nope.
And then, all
right, so, dice_val,
so this is all wrapped
in a function here.
So this is, theoretically,
let's see, is this the same--
I feel like this is the
same code, but just not
in a function.
And so, here, I feel like
if I wanted to rewrite this,
I would do something where I
would do like one dice roll.
And then my argument
would be button_01.
And then, I think I can leave
max_number_key as it is,
because that's already going
back to the UI element here.
That seems fair.
Seems fair, I
never know if I'm
walking into a trap with you.
I can't remember what
the renderText had.
Can we look at that
method, the bottom?
Down here?
dice_val.
Oh, it was using dice_val.
Yeah, so the dice, it
has dice_val, which
actually didn't use last_roll.
But we used last_roll
as a placeholder.
Ah, what we really
wanted is dice_val.
So the 54 should be
dice_val, not last_roll.
That was my fault.
That's all right.
All right, awesome.
Learning.
[LAUGHS] So we're going
to do one dice roll.
And then my button_key
is going to be--
OK, let me think about this.
Because the input is already
accounted for in my function,
I only need to provide
the button_key, which
is going to be button_01.
In quotes.
Oh, in quotes.
See.
And then, I don't need
to provide the max_value,
because that's already
a default, right?
Correct,
All right.
So this is the dice
roll for button_01.
And then, I'm
assuming I could do
one dice roll four button_02?
Yup.
All right.
And-- yeah, keep going.
I can, let me just
clean some things up here.
And then, I think I can get
rid of my second dice here.
So, last_roll_02, these guys.
And this.
Undo.
Not 81.
No.
Yeah, from there up.
All right, because then
we've got the output.
So, I'm assuming, would
the next step be--
I'll put dice_01.
OK, what are we doing?
Should we check our app?
What are the next steps?
So you have dice_val
and dice_val_02.
So one dice roll
returns a reactive.
So we should store that to
dice_val and dice_val_02.
The label there on 54 is good.
OK.
But we need to store the
result of 58 into a variable.
Got it.
And for fun, we
can say dice_val_01,
and then we'll update
65 to be dice_val_01.
(WHISPERING) Yeah.
This should work,
kind of exciting.
OK, we have a history
here of famous last words.
Sweet.
All right, let's
see what happens.
Let's set that to 20.
All right, so that's
working as expected.
Boom.
Our code is already a
little bit more efficient.
So we have functioni--
functionized?
Functionize, that's a word now.
We have functionalized
a dice roll,
with all of our reactives.
And now, we've got an output.
Perfect.
OK.
Are you telling me we can
make it more efficient.
I think, well, make
it more user friendly,
is kind of where it is.
So I like this, this
answer isn't bad.
It's a good stepping stone.
OK.
I would expect most people to
be able to create this function
and to execute this function.
Where we're going to go
next is a little bit more
into the rlang, into
closures, into expressions,
and things that don't
make sense right away,
but they're super powerful.
[LAUGHS] But that's
the r language.
We are choosing our pain now.
We are choosing the
user benefits, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
But we've done a lot of
the heavy lifting already.
We already have a
function that's there.
It's just, 58, when you look
at it, it's like one dice
roll of quote button_01.
I now have to remember that
that represents input dollar
button_01.
That's a little much.
Normally, we're used to
writing, reactive input dollar
button_01.
That's more familiar for me.
So, yeah, I think it'll work.
Let's go.
Let's do some closures!
Let them brace the closure fun.
Closures.
So, a little bit
of safeguarding,
let's actually make a
reactive between 37 and 39.
That is max number or
something like that.
It's a reactive of--
not reactive, just
playing reactive of,
and then we'll just do
our input max_number_key.
OK.
Awesome.
And then we'll replace input
max_number_key key in 44 and 46
with max_number.
Oh, OK, 44 and 46.
So while you're doing that,
there is no computational speed
up by--
Input dollar whatever is
a constant, static value.
So calling it twice
isn't a big deal.
Reactives, we have this
soft caching built in,
where we don't recalculate
everything twice.
So they're kind of
equivalent, but it gives you
a little bit more
freedom down the road
from where we're
going with this code.
44, 46 max_number
need to execute,
because we need to retrieve
the max_number value.
Awesome, great.
So let's test this just
to make sure this works.
And then, we can click
button, click button.
Awesome, great, OK.
So, closures, let's look at--
I really like this max_number
thing here in 39 and 40 to 41.
I think this is a very isolated,
quick, and easy thing to do.
Let's also add something
like, in the function up
at the top, instead of
max_number_key, maybe
we say like,
max_number_expression.
OK.
And I don't know
if you want to--
yeah.
Let's do just expr,
max_number_expr.
Great.
And let's go ahead and get
rid of the default value,
because that is
not what we want.
Oh, let's change our
function call down below
of one_dice_roll, and have--
down beneath, sorry, like
in 60s, 70s, [INAUDIBLE]..
That time.
Yeah, great, 60s.
Let's say the max_number_expr
equals input dollar,
what is it, select_max_number
or something?
Where, what?
Oh, sorry.
I'm not talking well here.
[LAUGHS] I feel like
I'm contagious and now
you're talking like me.
So what was the code that
we had before when we wanted
to retrieve the max number?
What was that code?
It was something
like input dollar.
Yeah, it was input
dollar select_max_number.
Great, let's put that
there in the second argument
to the function.
So you're saying input,
and then, we'll do--
I literally just said it.
select_max_number.
Yeah.
And we can do
$select_max_number,
because we're using
it directly, right?
Mm.
So, this is where
it gets interesting.
If we were to look at this
as a function, we could be--
if I'm interpreting this as is
right now, what this would do
is it would take the
max_number value right now,
and it would never update.
And it would never
listen to anything.
If it was just a
static value, we
would say, oh, the
max_number is zero.
And we move on, and it'll
never hit any reactivity.
This is how normal
functions would operate.
But what we want is we want to
have this expression be used
at a later date
and to allow Shiny
to re-execute that reactivity
over and over and over again.
And I think this is
just really neat things.
So let's move back
up to the reactive,
yeah, the max_number reactive.
And we now have the
max_number_expr.
Cool.
So let's go ahead and
duplicate 39 to 41,
so that we have
what we had before.
And then, this is our new stuff.
So, natural tendency,
right away, is to go ahead
and let's say, let's replace,
input bracket bracket
max_number_key with our
expression, so max_number_expr.
Right, so to do that.
N, just the whole line,
because max_number_expr
equaled input
$select_max_number, right?
So we're just kind
of swapping it in.
And, now, we're kind of
looking at and it's like, OK,
so we have a reactive,
and it's saying, retrieve
the value of max_number_expr.
Well, I have the value.
It's not really a
reactive expression.
Because if it's a function
right at the reactivity,
it's cut immediately, typically.
And you just receive
the value, and nothing
is going to work as you want.
And that stinks.
So this is where
we are wanting--
there's a thing
in rlang closures.
Do you think it would help
if we pulled up the docs?
Is that easy to--
Let me find the docs.
--do there?
All right, so we
are in the docs.
We've got some
metaprogramming patterns.
And we've got a little
bit of injection.
I see some of our
favorite words here.
I think most people
who are app developers
are familiar with dplyr.
And there's this
wonderful problem with--
or, not problem,
but situation that
occurs with dplyr, in
that, what if you want--
dplyr does this delayed--
or, not delayed, I
can't remember the name
metaprogramming, right?
Yeah.
So because you have the
ability to ask for column names
directly, what if you want a
variable to represent a column
name that you're
asking for directly?
And this gets a
little difficult.
Either you have to subset from
your calling dataframe, which
is not what we want to do.
And so, they have,
with rlang, we're now
able to do this using
these forwarding
patterns, such as
diffusing and injecting.
And I am very
familiar with the--
it's called the bang-bang
operator, or exclamation point
exclamation point,
paired with enquo.
Because I like to handle these
expressions very directly.
So, enquo, I would
grab it, and then I
would replace the
value using bang-bang.
And that is how I'm
familiar with it.
But if all you do is you
immediately do a bang-bang end
quote, and that's all
you do with the variable,
then you can use these
double curly brackets.
And these double curly brackets
is embraces or embracing,
and it's just a shorthand
version of bang-bang enquo.
I love it
So we're going to steal
this and use it within Shiny
within our function.
All right.
Recently, reactive, and
observe, and a few other methods
gained support for closures.
Hmm, OK.
And so, now we can
use these forwardings,
and embracing, and
whatnot. (WHISPERING) Yeah.
Do it.
[SIGHS] So--
Just embrace
everything, right?
So what I like to do at the
very beginning of a function
is to enquo all the
expressions that I
don't want to evaluate
now, but I want
to evaluate at a later time.
Are these creating promises?
Say again.
Are we creating promises?
According to the R package
promises, no, we are not.
But closures do feel like a
promise to evaluate something.
But it kind of
grabs the expression
and the environment where
that expression came from.
And then you can pass it
along the both of them.
Which usually, somewhere along
the way, in the olden times,
one of them would get
lost, and not a good thing
when that occurs.
And closures bundle
up into one and make
everything much better.
So let's go ahead
and after 35, we'll
say max_number_quo equals
enquo of max_number_expr.
So, max_number_quo--
Would I do a brand new one?
Yeah, a brand new
variable name, yep,
max_number_quo and will be the
enquo and of max_number_expr.
So, enquo quote is a method
that will turn your argument
name into a closure.
It is specifically meant to
be called inside a function.
If I was just in a script,
I might just use quo.
But inside a
function, it's enquo.
OK.
Is this packaging it up in its
own little special environment?
Say again.
Is this like putting
max_number_expr
in its own little
environment and just saying,
go sit on the shelf over here?
Yes, and it won't evaluate it.
OK.
So it's there, but it's
all bundled up on the shelf.
Yep.
It's for, like, later.
It's for later.
It's like a [AUDIO OUT]
for your birthday.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
We'll have to wait, OK.
And-- [LAUGHS] yes.
And let's go down to 46.
OK.
So, 46, reactive
is also something
that's expecting an expression.
So it's not something
that we could even
change it to max_number_quo
and it would work.
Because we still have
this issue of reactive
will just execute
the expression that
is there, which is saying
like, retrieve max_number_expr.
And that's not what we want.
We want it to actually--
it's very subtle, but we want
it to execute the closure--
or, execute the closure
expression, is what we want.
So to tell reactive
that I want you
to use the contents
of this variable
and not the text representation
of this variable,
we will use inject
with bang-bang.
And the inject will go
outside the reactive.
So close.
Bang-bang will stay there.
It's the way I described it.
[LAUGHS]
So close.
So you're saying
inject the reactive?
Yep.
And then let's go ahead and
take the curlies off of there,
just to help us think that I'm
now injecting the expression.
So I'm not giving an expression,
I'm injecting an expression.
But it's not the expr will do
the quo, the max_number_quo.
And the bang-bang is like
unwrapping our present.
Yeah, it's
unwrapping the present,
but not evaluating it yet.
So it's like a cool toy that
we've unwrapped but cannot yet
touch.
Yeah.
I think to kind of go with
this present is end quo, put it
in a shipping box, and
it's shipped to us.
And now, it's unwrapped and
it's available for reactive
to use and inject, put it in
there, like it snuck it in.
So let's go ahead
and comment 42, 44.
And I think this end--
did we replace max_number_expr
in both locations
down below, in the
one_dice_roll calls?
[INAUDIBLE], awesome.
Yeah.
So I think this will work.
No!
Oh no.
All right, let's do--
Enquo-- oh, library(rlang).
[LAUGHS]
Argh.
The number of times that
this has gotten me lately
is kind of surprising.
All right, are you ready?
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
All right, let's
see what happens.
Let's set this to--
Roll the dice.
--that number.
OK.
Look at that!
Sweet.
That's a really weird dice.
That would have to be a--
that's a good brainteaser,
how large would this dice ha--
Ginormous.
--die have to be?
It would have to be massive
to have that many sides.
It'd be like, roll the atom.
So let's go down to our function
calls that we are making.
(WHISPERING) All right.
So, it works, right?
Yeah.
And i think it's a
lot more representative
of what's happening.
So the user is saying here's
my reactive, select_max_number.
Let's actually change
this a little bit,
just to show that this is an
expression that's being done.
So for dice_val_01, let's go
ahead and put it in curlies
and say, just the
input$select_max_number,
just that part.
Oh, OK.
Oh, single curlies.
I know, I just
got really excited.
[LAUGHS] Can't embrace yet.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's do
select_max_number plus 5,
or something like that--
OK.
--something bigger.
And then, let's rerun the app.
And we should get, the first
die should have values up to 8.
And the second dice should
only have values up to 3.
So we got 7.
I just want to see
if we can hit 8.
I mean we might not,
laws of probability,
et cetera, et cet--
op, op, there we go.
Op, op.
And this will only be 1 to 3.
Yeah, look at that,
we did a little math
with our expression.
And so, this now
gives the caller
much more freedom as
to what they want to do
or things like that.
And the function logic
is all hidden away.
We can put it in the R folder.
We could source it from
somewhere else, maybe
a different package.
But this one_dice_roll
is now available.
Yeah I like it.
So let's actually
do the same treatment
with the button expression.
OK, this guy?
Yeah.
So instead of button_01, we
should turn it into something
like, input$button_01.
OK.
Yep.
[INAUDIBLE] at 71.
So you want to do both
here, let's do both.
All right.
Great.
[SIGHS] And one_dice_roll,
let's see that at the top.
So that's button_key.
So let's turn that
into button_expr.
And after 38, we will enquo
button_expr and store it
as button_quo.
I like just enquo-ing
everything at the top.
That way, you know
what's available.
[LAUGHTER]
And then, yep, we
can delete that.
And our button_quo
can be injected in 53.
53 is where we're going.
OK.
So we could just do, instead
of-- so it would be bindEvent
inject bang-bang button_quo?
And inject has to go
outside the bindEvent.
It's never going
to happen for me.
Yeah, it's a little off.
And then, to throw in
a little more wrinkles,
the pipe operator
from 52 is actually--
we want it to be for the Blind
event, the internal parameter,
not for the inject.
So we should pipe
to a curly bracket.
And that way-- yep.
And then, so now, this
is a magrittr expression.
And so we can bindEvent to dot
comma bang-bang button_quo.
dot comma, yeah.
So the dot represents
whatever was passed
into 53, yeah, that reactive.
And this should work.
So, reload app,
hopefully doesn't break.
[LAUGHS]
It did not.
All right, so the first one
should still go up to 8.
Great, much more than 3,
saw a couple 5s in there.
Great.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
Perfect.
All right, we did it.
We did the thing.
Whew, we did the thing.
Whew.
To me, this is
like a big journey,
but then the possibilities,
you just unlocked everything.
Now, the user can be
like, oh, I want to be
a button and something else.
Or I want it to be
a list of things.
Or, there's all sort--
I can now, as a user,
provide many things
for this expression, and
not just a single key
and be very limited to input
dollar or input bracket
bracket.
Yeah, so you've
expanded the scope
of what can be done with
the same amount of code.
You would add,
other features would
require more code, but not
necessarily more calculations.
Correct, absolutely.
The joke comes full
circle, let's embrace it.
Yeah.
We are only using the
expressions in one location.
And we are only, we enquo
it and we call it bang-bang.
So let's use the embrace
operator instead.
And then we can
just kind of get rid
of the intermediate operations.
So we're saying,
get rid of these.
Yep.
Aw.
All right, and now, do
we still need injects?
Or is inject handled
by my double curlies?
You still need inject.
The double curly is going
to be the replacement
for the bang-bang
and the enquo call.
Whoops, nope.
Yeah, so the embrace
operator is a double curly,
similar to the bang-bang.
It's something that rlang
looks for and has overwritten.
And max_number_quo
doesn't exist anymore,
so it needs to be
max_number_expr,
what it originally represented.
Great.
So then, here, I'm going to do
this guy, and it's button_expr.
And then, I do it again.
Great
And I think the formatting
is to put a space,
but I'm not entirely sure.
So we're going to go with it.
It's fine.
I like it.
Clear, it's very clear
that something is--
it kind of calls
your attention to it.
Like, mm, something's happening
that's maybe not what I expect.
Yes.
Unless you do
this all the time.
In which case, you expect it.
Even then, even then.
I think this will work.
Let's run it.
Run it!
All right, let's see.
We got a 6, we got an 8.
Yep, looks like everything
there is working.
I'm going to actually
jinx us and say,
I don't think we've ever had
a session where the app has
run so smoothly each time.
Yes.
It's also super helpful having
a working app to start with.
This is true.
[LAUGHTER]
So we were altering a
good app, versus creating it
from scratch.
That's true, that's true.
All right.
So is this it?
Are we now checkbox done?
Can we make this more efficient?
Or is this kind of--
That's it.
That's the journey.
All right, we made it.
I don't know the
Hobbit story very well.
So we went out, and then
we came back, right?
They make it back.
Yeah, they make it back.
Luckily, we didn't have
to pit stop at Mordor
and restart everything.
[LAUGHS]
If we have a minute
or two, let's
go ahead and add
reactlog, so we can see--
Here it is.
--what's happening.
All right.
I mean, it's one of my packages.
[INAUDIBLE]
I got promote it.
Who made reactlog, Barrett?
This wonderful developer,
her name's Barrett.
Yeah.
So let's do two parts.
So we did a library
up top, right?
And for developing
purposes, let's go
ahead, after 31,
say react_log_ui.
And we'll also do
something near 35, as well.
So, it's all good.
That's right.
Right, because you
put it in both places.
Mm-hmm, yeah.
So we need, basically, an
iframe into the reactlog.
So it's reactlog colon colon,
reactlog, is it not installed?
No, it is, I just didn't--
Oh, there we go.
[INAUDIBLE]
module_ui, the fourth
one there, great.
And defaults are good if you're
only using one, so that's good.
And then, just
inside the server,
I like to enable reactlog,
so reactlog colon
colon, reactlog_module_server.
Great.
And things should line up
with defaults, that's awesome.
So let's go ahead
and reload the app,
so that we can see all the
reactivity that's happening.
I'm Making this
larger for a reason.
[GASPS]
Oh, and we need to enable
reactlog at the beginning.
Yeah, after line 4, we can
say reactlog colon colon
reactlog enable.
Oh, just that?
reactlog_enable, yep.
All right.
Yeah.
And that does all the
settings for you, so that way,
it's just ready to go.
All right, let's look at
this gorgeous little app,
reactlog here.
So this is, we
have done nothing.
And this is what we've got.
Let's go ahead and actually
click each button once.
And then, up, up top, you
might have to go to the side.
Your face is in the way.
Ah.
Yeah, so let's click the roll
dice, roll a second dice.
And then, let's refresh now,
the orange refresh, yeah.
There we go, a little--
Look at that.
--bit more going on.
Look at all the
steps, step 27.
Yeah.
All we did was
click two buttons.
And the 27 is actually what
it took to get to an idle state.
So this isn't actually
even where we finished at.
Oh.
So this is right before
you clicked the first button
and then the second button.
So let's actually step
through that arrow.
Yeah.
And we can just
click a couple times.
So we clicked button one,
it's now invalidating
everything downstream, cool.
Then, the dice roll
is trying to update
from the bindEvent, is listening
getting the max number.
That was selected, things
are updating, great.
We're now going through
on the execution of it.
And then, good.
That was what happened
with one button.
The first button click.
Yeah.
Oh, and then the output of the
dice value is also updated.
And now, the first
button click is done.
OK.
Similar thing
will happen again
with second button clicks.
So it'll be the group below.
Oh, so we're seeing
the exact same thing.
But what's really
cool, to me, is things
like, it's using
input button_02.
Even though that
was the expression
that we had in
the function, that
was passed through
to the reactive.
Or, those different things that
were done, were passed through.
So I think it's nice to
see how that's occurring.
What's a little funny to see is
dice_val, is just hanging out,
nothing's connected to it.
What's happening here?
So, that is actually
that reactive is--
we can't alter the
reactive in place,
because it's something
that is not--
you can't alter the
variable and place safely.
So when a reactive
is sent to bindEvent,
a new reactive is created.
And so, that's
why in the middle,
there's a bindEvent of
dice_val to input button--
you can't see the full name--
but to input
button_02, and to input
button_one if you
go to the one above.
So that actually
replaced dice_val.
OK.
I think it's pretty neat
to see that that's what's
occurring underneath the hood.
Because you did
create the dice_val,
reactive, but we tossed it
away when we called bindEvent.